the mystery of who murdered a
pennsylvania teacher remains unsolved
more than a year after she was killed 33
year old Rachel Dell Tondo was gunned
down in the driveway of her parents home
in Aliquippa Pennsylvania just outside
Pittsburgh there are multiple leads but
no arrests have been made many are
blaming the lack of an arrest on an
underfunded and understaffed Police
Department for 48 hours Erin Moriarty is
following the investigation just over a
year ago on Mother's Day 2018 33
year-old Rachel don't Hondo was shot
several times at close range just
outside her home her father Joe Dell
Tonda was asleep by the side door when
he heard the shots I'm walking in a door
she was our life Rachel's death is the
ninth unsolved murder in the city of
Aliquippa Pennsylvania although there
appear to be plenty of avenues for
police to investigate
starting with 21 year old Sheldon Jeter
Rachel's mother Lisa he was obsessed
with her he told me he's in love with
her
Michael Santa Kola and I represent
Sheldon Jeter person of interest in this
particular case I think it's fair to say
that he's a suspect but there is a cast
of characters that all could be
considered suspects I would say her
fiance is a possible suspect I'm Frank
Atropa experience' of rachel don't under
why would people think you had have been
involved somehow well maybe just you
know we had a long relationship she told
me a long time ago her ex-fiance was
gonna kill her Franklin asked you
directly did you have anything to do
with the death of Rachel Dale Tondo
absolutely not
Rachel told her parents that she was
cooperating in an ongoing investigation
by state police into alleged corruption
in the Aliquippa Police Department and
that she had received death threats she
was afraid of the police deathly afraid
to police she said their fall on you
Mima they're following me
Joe Percival was assistant chief of
police when Rachael was murdered do you
think that anyone in the police
department was involved in any way in
Rachel's death you just never know
Alec what was a small community what New
York problems
I heard Moriarty joins us at the table
here and there's a great soundbite but
you know this is a real cautionary tale
of how important it is to have a very
functional police department you can't
solve or prevent crime
if you don't number one have a
functional police department have people
have faith in the police department well
it's so what here's what I understand
why was a local teacher involved in a
corruption investigation the police
department no we were kind of surprised
by that too and it's not clear what she
knew but there was no question that she
was talking to State Police and the
State Police has been investigating
allegations of corruption within the
police department within the city she
then said she was being followed by
police officers she she did get death
threats some texts like you won't live
to see the end of 2018 so and she didn't
and so I think people think that there
could have been a hit but then the DA
says no no this is not a problem of what
she knew but who she knew that this was
a crime of passion if you had a really
functional Police Department that was
still working on a dimensional were they
well right in less than a month after
she was murdered there were three police
chiefs in one week sorry three police
chiefs one win one week and in fact they
turned over the investigation into her
murder to the county are they any closer
to finding Rachael's killer well if you
talk to the DA they are but it's been a
year and you know usually DEA DNA tests
don't take a full year and that's what
we were told is the holdup well you
certainly feel for the parents you can
really feel and see their pain very sad
story for them Thank You Erin
you can watch Erin Moriarty's 48 hours
report it's called what happened to
Rachel Saturday at 10:00 9:00 central
right here on CBS